aquí tenemos el modelo molecular del
ciclo hexano y desde esta perspectiva
parece que es plano pero si lo giramos
podemos ver que no es plano a esto se le
llama conformación de silla si
observamos desde estos dos carbonos
podemos ver la conformación de silla en
la proyección de newman observen que
tenemos a los hidrógenos alternados aquí
tenemos las fotografías de la
conformación de silla se les llama
conformación de silla porque si la
dibujamos así tenemos un lugar para
recargar nuestra cabeza y espalda
también tenemos el asiento y tenemos un
lugar para que descansen nuestros pies
aquí tenemos el dibujo de la
conformación de silla vamos a compararlo
con la fotografía empecemos con este
carbono que será nuestro carbono 1
corresponde a este carbono este carbono
tiene dos hidrógenos
y está después tenemos este enlace que
corresponde a este y nos lleva al
carbono 2 que también tiene dos
hidrógenos después tenemos este enlace
que corresponde a este y aquí tenemos
nuestros hidrógenos el siguiente enlace
baja un poco corresponde a este enlace y
nos lleva a este carbono le ponemos sus
dos hidrógenos el siguiente enlace se
regresa
después tenemos este enlace de atrás que
corresponde a este enlace y este carbono
también tiene dos hidrógenos finalmente
este enlace sube un poco corresponde a
éste y hemos regresado al carbono 1
ahora veamos la proyección de newman
ésta es la que vimos en el vídeo vamos a
dibujarla empecemos con este carbono lo
representamos con un punto y podemos ver
que hay un hidrógeno hacia arriba vamos
a dibujarlo después tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia abajo y hacia la izquierda hacia
abajo y hacia la izquierda después hacia
abajo y hacia la derecha tenemos un ch
todos que no lo escribiré pero hay
ahora el carbono de atrás lo podemos ver
un poco en la fotografía por la
perspectiva pero en realidad el carbono
de adelante tapa completamente al
carbono de atrás que lo representamos
con un círculo y que tenemos en el
carbono de atrás bueno tenemos este
hidrógeno está hacia arriba y hacia la
izquierda también tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia abajo y después tenemos un ch 2
hacia arriba y hacia la derecha ahora
vamos con este carbono de la derecha que
lo representamos con un punto tiene un
hidrógeno hacia arriba justo aquí
después tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo
y hacia la derecha ahí está y luego
tenemos este enlace que nos conecta con
el grupo ch todos
entonces nos queda así ahora dibujemos
nuestro carbono de atrás y unido a este
carbono tenemos un hidrógeno que va
hacia arriba y hacia la derecha después
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo
hidrógeno abajo y finalmente tenemos un
enlace que nos lleva a éste sh2 entonces
esta es nuestra proyección de newman
para la conformación de silla observen
que todos los hidrógenos estan
alternados así que no tenemos que
preocuparnos por la tensión torsional
además en la conformación de silla los
enlaces tienen ángulos muy cercanos a
los ideales ciento 9.5 grados porque los
ángulos de los enlaces carbono-carbono
son aproximadamente de 111 grados
por eso la conformación de silla es la
conformación más estable para el ciclo
extra
ahora echemos un vistazo a la
conformación de bote aquí tenemos la
conformación de bote del ciclo hexano
porque los carbonos forman algo parecido
a un bote pero aunque pocas cosas pueden
desestabilizarlo
una de ellas son estos hidrógenos de
arriba que están muy cerca se le conoce
como interacción de astabandera si
observamos estos dos carbonos el de
adelante y el de atrás encontramos la
proyección de newman y podemos ver que
hay una fuente de atención torsional
estos hidrógenos estan eclipsados con
los hidrógenos de atrás y hay muchos
ejemplos de tensión torsión al que
desestabilizan a la conformación de bote
esta es la conformación de bote del
vídeo vamos a compararlo con el dibujo
este enlace corresponde a este enlace lo
puse más largo en el dibujo para poder
ver mejor los hidrógenos
este carbono corresponde a este y vamos
a dibujar sus dos hidrógenos después
tenemos un enlace que va hacia este
carbono corresponde a este enlace y
luego tenemos dos hidrógenos unidos a
este carbono después tenemos este enlace
hacia abajo que corresponde a este y nos
lleva al carbono de atrás que también
tiene dos hidrógenos aquí y aquí es
difícil ver esos hidrógenos en la
fotografía pero aquí tenemos uno y el
otro se encuentra por acá después
tenemos este enlace que corresponde a
este y tenemos nuestros hidrógenos en
este carbono después subimos a este
carbono subimos y vamos a dibujar
nuestros hidrógenos finalmente
regresamos a este carbono que
corresponde
a este y dibujamos sus dos hidrógenos
observen que la interacción de
astabandera ocurre cuando este hidrógeno
queda muy cerca de este eso aumenta la
tensión en la conformación de bote
espero que puedan ver la forma de un
bote en esta conformación no hay mucha
atención angular pero si hay tensión
torsional y para eso necesitamos la
proyección de newman entonces observemos
esta fotografía y dibujemos la
conformación de newman empecemos con
este carbono que se representa con un
punto y después tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia arriba y hacia la izquierda que
corresponde a este después tenemos un
hidrógeno hacia abajo ahí está y hacia
arriba y hacia la derecha tenemos un ch
todos
ahora dibujemos el carbono de atrás aquí
tenemos nuestro círculo que representa
al carbono de atrás y observen que los
hidrógenos del carbono de atrás están
eclipsados con los hidrógenos de
adelante
entonces los dibujaré un poquito chuecos
para verlos mejor
el enlace de atrás casi no se ve pero
sabemos que atrás hay un enlace que nos
lleva a otro ch2 ahora vamos con este
carbono que lo representamos con un
punto y observen que este caso es el
mismo que este solo que en sentido
contrario entonces tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia arriba y hacia la derecha después
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo y luego
tenemos este enlace que nos lleva a este
grupo ch2 así que este enlace se une con
este aquí está nuestro ch todos
en el carbono de atrás aquí está nuestro
círculo tenemos un hidrógeno hacia
arriba y hacia la derecha después
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo y
finalmente tenemos un enlace que nos
lleva al otro grupo ch2 esta es nuestra
proyección de newman aquí podemos ver
todos los hidrógenos eclipsados y por lo
tanto la tensión torsional así que la
conformación de bote es más alta en
energía comparada con la conformación de
silla porque la conformación de silla es
menor en energía y bueno en realidad
existen otras con formaciones para el
ciclo hexano si torcemos un poco la
conformación de bote podemos obtener
otras con formaciones como la torcida y
la media silla pero por ahora no nos
interesan esas con formaciones así que
en los siguientes vídeos nos enfocaremos
en la conformación de silla
que el ciclo hexano pasa la mayor parte
del tiempo en esa conformación